Trevor T Martin Martin oh my god
and Tom pro syndicate castle yes okay
love you are two popular youtubers who
in late 2015 came up with an incredible
scheme to make them rich oh my god they
were gonna run a classic casinos scale
Oh specifically they were gonna get
people hooked on a csgo gambling site
that they own but not tell anybody that
they owned it
we found this new site called csgo wadda
wadda and had all the makings of a great
skate dude you could just swing for the
fences with one bet and just cover way
up five grand
the only problem was that csgo gambling
was a massive underground industry that
chugs along in the dark alleys beneath
the squeaky-clean exterior of csgo
eSports and these two dingus has managed
to explode and expose one of gaming's
biggest grain markets with just a few
simple videos
[Music]
what forever watch forever
what
[Music]
you just won 9 grand you just wonder I
know and granted we started from the
shite now we're here
holy tits on a [ __ ] pancake it all
started in December 2015 when team
Martin incorporated csgo Watteau csgo
gambling so now while the trend is died
down a little ceaseless kin gambling was
all the rage just a few years ago see
every skin is bought and sold on the
steam marketplace which gives it a real
world value now if you fool the skin on
the few marketplace right now you'd get
scheme credit but there are plenty of
ways to turn those skins into a party
there were two primary ways to gamble
with skins you could either bet on the
results of an eSports match or play a
game like roulette oh [ __ ] we're
spinning boys we're spinning
what do you good knives there's some
good knives just holy [ __ ] that's what
we're talking about but cashing out
through these gambling sites and steam
box only gave you the value you won in
skins the real game came in the skinny
gray market websites that let you trade
your skins to someone else in exchange
for money through say PayPal it was just
like a real casino
well almost basically you turn your real
human earth money into scam either by
buying them in the steam marketplace or
buying keys to open crates that contains
them you took your skins to the gambling
site of your choice traded them to their
BOTS for a new fake currency that was
roughly equivalent to US dollars which
they were your casino chips you then bet
that money with that currency on either
matches or roulette spins to win more
money which you then turned back into
skins and finally you sold those skins
to someone through another site to get
back a real human life and now that you
understand how skin gambling works you
might be asking to yourself how was all
this illegal well it wasn't at least not
technically see a lot of these sites
scurried around gambling regulations by
arguing that technically you weren't
gambling with
money you were gambling with a virtual
item and while it had a real-world value
you could technically get it through a
random crate or a drop and then you
weren't winning money just skin and yes
skins do have real-world value but valve
didn't let you get that money natively
through Steam we'll be coming back to
the legality of all of this later on but
for now remember that csgo a game with a
massive underage audience had a powerful
and prevalent underground gambling Sam
so tmartn and his associates including
popular youtuber pro syndicate started
csgo Watteau dot-com a skin gambling
site to profit off the crates but they
took it one step further you don't make
money if no one is gambling at your
casino but advertising is expensive and
yes the lotto had plenty of competition
meanwhile prote syndicate and tmartn had
massive YouTube channels each with
millions of subscribers if they could
get the word out about csgo Watteau to
their huge audiences they were
guaranteed to see at least some success
good day
holy [ __ ] a third year six table out
there and a 719 go about their holy cow
let's go boys but more importantly
neither youtuber mentioned the fact that
they were part owners of csgo Auto calm
they just kept making videos winning
money and losing money on roulette spins
and coin flips just like they were
anybody else and not part owners of the
website can we take it W yes yes yes yes
yes
but someone noticed a youtuber called to
honor the call released a video on June
27th 2016 that first made the
allegations that Team Arden and Pro
Syndicate were partners in csgo whattodo
calm hold on to your pants it's about to
go down this may be the biggest scandal
in Cod community which has nothing to do
with Call of Duty let me be clear here
I'm not accusing anyone I found some
info and I want to show it to our
viewers
so tmartn and purse indicate visit a
csgo gambling site called csgo Lauro
calm I did some digging into this and
holy [ __ ]
this site was registered as a business
in Orlando Florida I thought it's just a
coincidence since tmartn also lives in
Orlando but no it wasn't Trevor Martin
aka T Martin is the director of this
site he [ __ ] owns the damn site
he also accused the pair of faking their
reactions to their big wins and losses
in their YouTube videos these two on the
website CS Gallardo comm and the
allegedly do fake gambling and pretend
to win thousands of dollars and also
sometimes pretend to lose it to those
claims were further backed up by popular
YouTube channel h3h3 productions who
released the video going over honor the
calls allegations and pointing out that
whether or not tee Martin and Pro
syndicate were manipulating the results
the fact that they could just wasn't a
good look so here he you know fairy tale
story you know fifty dollars up to
thousands and a 13 minute video terrific
stuff guys do you think it's possible he
faked his reaction and faked the actual
results of the big bet it's possible
it's very possible I don't know if he
did but it's possible and that's why you
don't gamble on your own psyche it
doesn't need to be sent it's just it's
obscene so with all the allegations out
there how do you see Martin and Pro
syndicate react well syndicates took the
high ground and apologized and promised
any more transparent the future but he's
been in trouble for doing things like
this before
so it remains to be seen how genuine
that was but team Martin's double damn
what screw not guys team art here and so
hope you guys having a fantastic Monday
I just wanted to make a quick little
vlog to talk to you guys and kind of lay
everything out on the line give you guys
the full true story straight from the
source
because unfortunately and I really I
don't understand kind of where it's
coming from but there is going to be a
little bit of a [ __ ] storm headed this
way and some of the drama channels are
gonna pick up on it I'm sure a lot of
the hater channels are gonna pick up on
it but I wanted you guys to know exactly
what's going on so you guys could make
your own well-informed decisions
basically what's breaking news now is
that myself and a few other people
including Tom or pro syndicate own csgo
ATO and this is something that has never
been a secret I don't understand why
it's this big breaking news now because
it's never been like under wraps it's
never been a secret the problem is that
it was a secret at least to his viewers
and that's the attention of the United
States Federal Trade Commission he
didn't take kindly to the whole
situation and watched an investigation
into those tmartn and pro syndicate a
few days after that tee Martin released
an apology video that he quickly took
down probably because the FTC was
already asked about Cooper I have no
idea how I'm gonna record this video
dude now my connection to csgo lotto has
been a matter of public record since the
company was first organized in December
of 2015 however I do feel like I owe you
guys an apology I am sorry to each and
every one of you who vote like that was
not made clear enough to use the FTC
taking interest in two youtubers sparked
headlines that made some people notice
that Valve appeared to be enabling
underage gambling which led some people
to file class-action lawsuits against
vows see there's no way of knowing for
sure but it seems like a valve had to
have known that people are using csgo
skins as gambling chips if seem like
there's pretty much no way for them not
to have known plus some people at the
time argue that the growth of csgo
gambling was in turn good for the growth
of valve so valve has denied that how to
blow 500 bucks in a couple of minutes
featuring rocky tmartn for one it meant
more people were playing csgo which is
good for valor but more importantly now
if it's a 15% cut on every sale in the
steam marketplace so every skin bought
is money in a valve pocket - and when so
many players were rapidly cashing skins
in with boss than cashing them out to
turn their liquid asset into a solid one
that was theoretically breaking in
but even valve can't stand up to us
gambling laws and eventually they sent
out cease and desist letters to 23 csgo
skin gambling sites including csgo Votto
the problem is that allegations about
valves involvement with skin gambling
ran deeper than that according to the
letter valve sent out the sites were
violating the steam subscriber agreement
by using steam accounts for commercial
game however you have to think that
Valve knew about this it wasn't a secret
just ignored 1180 we back to our
intrepid scam artist t Martin and Pro
Syndicate managed to avoid any jail time
and didn't even get fine the FCC let
them off with a slap on the wrist
despite having been found to have paid
of other youtubers and twitch streamers
between two thousand five hundred and
fifty five thousand dollars to promote
csgo Waldo without disclosing that
relationship all they had to do was
admit they were in the wrong and they
have to disclose any relationship like
this in the future but how did key
Martin approach to they could get away
with it well there was this weird at we
for speaking the polygon T Martin and
person that gets lawyer Coleman Watson
explained that Cisco auto wasn't
technically gambling see if you look
closely at the terms of use csgo what is
said that by using the site you were
acknowledging that you could at any
point ask for an alternative method of
entry to any game on the site that's
right you didn't have to pay if you just
read the fine print you would know that
csgo water will let you play for free as
many times as you want it holy cow lets
you go boys it's not like CF goes
gambling underground would have lasted
that much longer without all this
publicity T Martin and Pro Syndicate
didn't single-handedly tank it this was
a massive unregulated gambling industry
that people are gonna notice eventually
but they're dumb scam is why people
notice that when they did but while they
were driving off to the sunset the csgo
gambling industry was blowing up
they may have burned down the casino but
they still got out of it with all of
their ill-gotten gains thanks for
watching if you want more great content
just like this be sure to hit the
subscribe button
[Music]